when you are excited about something or
you really want to attend to something
it literally brings about a narrowing of
the aperture of your visual window and
your auditory window so that you attend
to this particular location in space we
have an aperture or window on our focus
mental focus follows visual focus is
there advice you have for
how to achieve focus first of all we
have to distinguish between modulators
and mediators and i'll do this very
briefly there are a lot of things that
will modulate your state of focus but
they don't
directly mediate your sense of focus so
for instance if right now a fire alarm
went off in this building it would
modulate our attention we would get up
and leave it'd be very hard to do what
we're doing with that banging in the
background at least at first so it's
modulating focus but it's not really
involved in the mechanisms of focus
right now in terms of things that
mediate focus it's very clear that
mental focus follows visual focus
provided that you're a sighted person
much of the training that's being done
now in china to teach kids to focus
better literally has them stare at a
target blinking every so often but
really training themselves to breathe
calmly and maintain a tight visual
aperture when you read you have to
maintain a tight visual aperture you're
literally scrolling like a highlighter
in your mind's eye right it's kind of
obvious once you hear it so for people
that have problems focusing sleep well
learn to dilate and contract your visual
field consciously this can be done
if you practice it a little bit as i
said before it is very hard to get into
a state of focus like a step function
immediately like snapping your fingers
what you can do is you can pick any
object but ideally an object at roughly
the same distance placed at roughly the
same distance to which you're going to
do that work and stare at it you're
allowed to blink and as your mind starts
to drift every once in a while to
understand that's normal but try and
narrow your visual aperture and bring
that into your visual field so that
that's the most prominent thing and then
after doing that for 30 to 60 seconds
moving into the work that you're about
to do and really encourage yourself to
do that in the same way being well
rested when you sleep your autonomic
nervous system that adjusts states of
alertness and focus and calm works
better than when you're sleep-deprived
so if you're sleeping better you're
going to focus better the best thing
that anyone can do for their mental
health physical health and performance
in athletic or cognitive endeavors or
creative endeavors is to make sure that
you're getting enough quality sleep
enough of the time for you and then of
course the pharmacologic tools just
enough caffeine but not too much right
um we talked about white noise brown
noise music or no music really varies
but it's very clear that binaural beats
of 40 hertz
can shift the brain into a heightened
state of focus and cognition so if
you're going to use binaural beats which
should definitely be used with
headphones there are other frequencies
that are interesting but 40 hertz
binaural beat seems to be the one that
there's the most quality research on and
then i suppose the the other thing for
focus is um workplace optimization
where you place your screen is important
staring down at a screen is not going to
be as effective as placing it at eye
level or above you when the eyes are up
literally your eyes are directed forward
or up the brainstem centers for
alertness are activated when your eyes
are down it's actually you're you're
sort of it's like being pulled under
water a little bit in the autonomic
arousal sense there's been some really
interesting studies that when people
work in small compact spaces or wear a
hoodie or a hat that can also
improve focus like blinders on a horse
but also analytic work or the kind of
work where there's a correct answer that
you're seeking
is best supported by these kind of low
ceiling environments whereas there's
something called the cathedral effect
which is when you work in an outdoor
environment or a high ceiling
environment it lends itself to kind of
pun intended kind of loftier ideas and
more creativity and that probably has to
do with the fact that there's a natural
tendency a reflex to expand your visual
field in these high ceiling environments
expansion of the visual field changes
the way the brain works in the time
domain the best way to think about it is
when you have a narrow focus portrait
mode on your phone or you're very alert
you are fine slicing life in time it's
like a
think of it as a high frame rate like
you're shooting in slow motion when you
have a
when you dilate your v your view you're
taking bigger time bins and the one way
to just let this hopefully land home is
that if you've ever had a really
exciting day
or podcast interview or experience of
any kind your system is flooded with
dopamine and norepinephrine alertness
and motivation all this excitement it
seems like it goes by very very fast and
yet when you think back to that it seems
like a lot happened this happened then
that happened now think about waiting in
the doctor's office in a blank waiting
room with no interesting art on the
walls it feels like it goes by very very
slow dopamine and norepinephrine are all
time low and yet when you think back on
that experience it's as if nothing
happened because you were parsing time
and you mentioned being you know kind of
uh cramming for for something well
you'll release a lot of adrenaline and
you'll it is true you can get a lot done
under pressure because of the way that
you're slicing time you don't actually
have more time it's that you're finally
in a brain state that lends itself well
to parsing information really quickly
now if we ramp up your level of stress
enough it's definitely a you know it's a
more or less normal distribution we get
you stressed enough it's hard to
remember anything you're not parsing
time well but in that middle range
almost every study shows that the higher
levels of autonomic arousal meaning
norepinephrine adrenaline in your system
the more effective you are at things